so black holes what is a black hole a
black hole is just a region of space
where gravity is so strong that nothing
can come out of there right not even
light the the boundary of the black hole
is called the event horizon and the
history of black holes is a great study
in humility because we kept discovering
over and over again that we were all
wrong about them first when Einstein
wrote down his equations of gravity this
guy called Schwarzschild discovered the
black hole solution and then from
decades and decades people thought that
actually the event horizon itself was
some kind of singularity was something
what's really weird with space then it
turned out that was just this math error
people had made and there's nothing
special that happens if you fall through
the event horizon except the D if you're
keeping track you have a sinking feeling
which if you're never coming back yeah
it's like the event horizon of a black
hole is like if you're swimming in the
Niagara River upstream from the
waterfall there's one particular line
through the river where the water
accelerates to go faster than you can
swim you're not gonna die there you just
gonna have that oh [ __ ] moment
experience yeah and and then people
thought well you know you're gonna only
die when you come into the middle of a
black hole where there is this thing
called the singularity either a point or
a ring depending on whether it's
spinning then it turned out actually
there is another thing called the inner
horizon where you might actually die
earlier by hitting things that come at
you at the speed of light and then very
recently there's a firewall hypothesis
saying actually maybe you do die after
all that the event horizon yeah and the
short answer as to what the truth is is
we really don't know we're studying and
it's a key in understanding the theory
of everything yeah because it turns out
that they're really rigorously answer
these questions it's not enough to just
work with Einstein's theory gravity you
also have to throw in quantum mechanics
into that and those are the two theories
we mentioned earlier don't get along so
you don't ultimately know so the way I
see it
is actually as an opportunity if we can
figure out what's going on with black
holes and they may even get some clues
by looking at them then that can
actually made it be the master key that
can help us unlock some of the deepest
mysteries of quantum gravity yes
yeah a unified theory of physics